the morality of having kids in a burning
drowning world the writer of the article
Jessica winter Begins by recounting the
time when she read a newspaper article
with quote an apocalyptic 50-year
climate forecast and resolved in that
moment to never have any kids of her own
but she soon confesses that she did end
up having kids two of them who are now
nine and six and she now seems to be
plagued with doubt and guilt because of
her choice to have kids a decision that
she insists is uh ethically complex
quote should I have a child they green
house gas emissions will cause roughly
50 square meters of sea ice to melt
every year that they're alive Rush
writes just by existing they will make
the world a little less livable for
everyone themselves included now the
idea of making your own life less
livable by living in the first place is
of course totally nonsensical